el lenguaje algebraico es otra manera de
comunicar y representar las operaciones
matemáticas y la verdad es que lo has
usado desde hace mucho tiempo observa
las siguientes imágenes
estas fórmulas de figuras geométricas
son expresiones algebraicas porque están
compuestas de números letras y
operaciones matemáticas
una forma divertida de aprender
expresiones algebraicas es usando
figuras geométricas vamos a crear
algunas con este tapete de colores qué
expresión algebraica podríamos usar para
calcular el área de este tapete fácil
primero identifiquemos el tipo de
figuras que tiene hay cuadrados y
rectángulos de diferentes tamaños es
conveniente que veamos cada una de estas
figuras por separado para poder calcular
sus áreas y así crear una sola expresión
para todo nuestro tapete
comencemos con el cuadrado cada uno de
sus lados lo representaremos con la
letra a porque todos tienen la misma
medida en álgebra a cada una de las
letras de una expresión se le llama
literal
recordemos que la fórmula para calcular
el área de un cuadrado es lado por lado
o lo que es lo mismo lado al cuadrado
entonces esta primera figura quedaría
como a cuadrada agreguemos un signo de
más a esta primera expresión que ya
formamos cada uno de estos elementos
recibe el nombre de término algebraico
sigamos con el rectángulo mayor cuya
fórmula de área es base por altura
representaremos sus lados con las
literales b y c una será la base y la
otra la altura así que la expresión
sería b por c en el lenguaje algebraico
dos letras juntas representan una
multiplicación por lo que nuestra
segunda figura quedará como b c bien
ahora asumimos este término con a
cuadrada y pongamos un signo de más para
el siguiente continuamos con los cuatro
cuadrados pequeños aquí podemos formar
dos expresiones como nuestra figura es
un cuadrado debemos aplicar lo mismo que
hicimos con el cuadrado amarillo vamos a
elevar uno de sus lados al cuadrado
representaremos el lado con la literal d
así la primera expresión sería sumar de
cuadrada más de cuadrada más de cuadrada
más de cuadrada la segunda opción sería
multiplicar de cuadrada por 4 ya que
tenemos un total de 4 cuadritos
utilicemos 4 x de cuadrada para
agregarle a la expresión que estamos
creando
así que tenemos a cuadrada más de
porsche más 4 x de cuadrada más lo que
sigue continuamos con el rectángulo más
angosto
mira este lado del rectángulo tiene la
misma medida que los lados del cuadrado
por lo tanto vamos a dejarlo con la
literal
y el otro lado lo nombraremos con la
letra 'e' entonces la expresión de este
rectángulo sería a por que escribamos
este nuevo término a la expresión que
estamos formando
a cuadrada más de porsche más cuatro por
de cuadrada más a porque sigamos con el
último rectángulo vamos a retomar el
lado representado por a y lo
multiplicaremos por f así que nuestra
expresión será a por efe bien subimos
este último término y tendremos completa
la expresión que representa el área del
tapete nuestra expresión algebraica
sería a cuadrada más de porsche más
cuatro por de cuadrada más a por más
por efe súper hagamos otro ejercicio
ahora vamos a encontrar expresiones
algebraicas equivalentes entre sí veamos
nuevamente nuestro tapete
qué interesante ya viste aquí tenemos el
rectángulo angosto y los cuatro
cuadrados a simple vista notamos que
tienen la misma proporción entonces
podemos decir que estas figuras son
equivalentes vamos a representar las de
la siguiente manera a x es igual a 4 x
de cuadrada listo hasta podríamos
establecer una expresión más si en
nuestro tapete comparamos a por efe con
a x y más 4 x de cuadrada nuestra
equivalencia quedaría a por efe es igual
a 4 por de cuadrada más a por e
que otras expresiones podemos igualar a
simple vista con el tapete como sería la
expresión para igualar el cuadrado
amarillo con estas figuras de la derecha
te invito a seguir descubriendo esta y
otras expresiones algebraicas más